Liam Keely was born in South Africa and
began his martial arts training at the
age of 10 with judo after completing his
Bachelor of Arts he moved to Japan in
1974 to further his practice of Goju Ryu
karate arriving in Tokyo
he began practice at the famous Yoyogi
dojo of the now legendary he go on a
morio since a living in Tokyo became
acquainted with people like hunter
Armstrong and he introduced me to the
group of people that surrounded draga
in 1979 I was invited to join the AI HRC
research team Liam travelled to Malaysia
and Indonesia in 1979 with Dondre ger
and a team of other halal adjusts
learning directly from dragor his
approach to the study in classification
of martial arts weaponry and culture saw
became somewhat better acquainted with
Don dragon he was a very impressive man
and he had a big effect on me because of
his mentor each I decided that the thing
to do was to go back to South Africa and
do a degree in social anthropology so
that was in 1980 beginning like daily
just after I got graded so down in
Okinawa go to Dubai he going Oh sensei
so while in South Africa I got I
researched dualistic fighting and I was
involved in the making of a
groundbreaking documentary on silver
stick fighting
I returned to Japan in 1984 and through
draggers influence I thought the thing
to do would be to get into one of the
really old of styles one of the old
Cordia returning to Japan in 1984 he
began his study of Tatsumi REO under
cattle takashi sensei in which he holds
the rank of oka don muraco and later
began training at Toraja Booga REO an
anita Suseo sensei in which he holds the
rank of shihan-dai currently on
residence in australia and i teach to
courtier totaku career naginata Jitsu
and Tatsu media along the way I also
picked up all sorts of other stuff
including Chen style Tai Chi which I did
for about 15 years in Japan Liam has
continued to promote collaboration and
education in the martial arts as a
member of the Japan martial arts society
through organizing the first
international hopper ology conference in
1996 and were recently as a co-founder
the choreo collective in spite of
suffering from Parkinson's disease he is
still training and teaching for me
apology is very interesting it's a more
academic study of human combat combative
behavior but it's not for everybody I
realized that I think authenticity is
really important so I think you need to
be aware of your lineage it doesn't
matter what you study and another
important point is I think it's
important to be able to respect your
teacher I've had friends study with
people that were very good martial
artists but not particularly nice people
I think if you're going to associate
with people especially over a long
period of time it's important to be able
to have a good atmosphere and trust
people the people that you've chosen to
associate with and will say something
about you I mean the Japanese Center
saying which is say to our sensei no
kagami
now I think it were to expose what is
what dragger taught and how you get
styled so hop Lola G comes from the
greek root hobble meaning armed or
armoured so the Greek warrior the
classical warrior who fought with for
example it's mop ally with spear and
shield the shield is the hopalong the
person is the hoplite and the study of
uncomfort armed conflict is hot balaji
the Dorian of topology is generally
considered to be sir richard francis
burton some of you may be familiar with
his his name so it was a victorian
multi-talented men with severe
personality drawbacks enough to get me
well this is an interesting picture it's
why I think Layton you can see the scar
across his jaw when she got from a
Somali spear thrust something said it
done changed so after after Burton
passed away there was a bit of a gap
between there's a bit of a gap between
Burton and dragon however there were
Westerners involved in martial arts in
the Meiji era so I've got a quick
selection or four people here we have
actually a German it's his Austrian but
he worked for the Austrian embassy
Heinrich von Sibbald
was a diplomat another German doctor
Allen bolts newest physician to the
imperial family to English Englishman EJ
Harrison who did tension chin Yuri and
early form of Judah he wrote a book
called the fighting spirit of Japan and
then we have FJ Norman
who was a British officer I think
cavalry officer and it ended up teaching
at a Tajima naval school and I think it
was Thani you found the book and drew
two Alexes attention and yet you later
put out another edition of that what
particularly interested me in this book
is a hot lawyer just was he mentioned to
people as being probably the two best
Kendall kya at that time in Japan and
since I do talks the media I was quite
fascinated to find that one of the
people he was talking about was Henry
Sasuke who was the son of a headmaster
of Tatsu media and the kenjutsu Chien
for the Tokyo Metropolitan Police and
the other person was of course sir
occupier kenkichi fourteenth headmaster
of kashi machined ng chicago dear anyway
that's by the way let me talk very
little about Don Drago
so I think we've got most of this
information from chip so it maybe will
let me focus on the very last point
martial arts mentor definitely been part
of the 1979 field trip to Malaysia
Indonesia changed my life been exposed
to Draya seeing how he operated
absorbing his ideas made big difference
to my life I decided I was to some
extent wasting my time in Japan because
I don't never strong through a
theoretical basis so what I did was go
back to South Africa I really had a
degree in classical life and thought so
I did a equivalent degree in
anthropology and then they allowed me to
do another year of honors and
anthropology and while in South Africa I
was able to get into Zula stick fighting
I went to my old University and started
off the archaeology department they very
when I explained what kind of thing I
was looking for they suggested I visit
the anthropology department and
introduced me to a gentleman by the name
of Johnny Clegg who later became very
well known as a pop musician afro-pop in
South Africa so Johnny in turn
introduced me to a gentleman by the name
of papasan Palmer a Zulu from mattel
Sabbatini area and he became my teacher
of Silla stick fighting he was living in
Legally on the campus in the city
security guards barracks and I became a
visitor to the security guard Derrick's
they were all the silver and I think
they enjoyed seeing me get beaten up so
I would go along to the barracks and
actually the dog guard dogs they too
bothersome was a very interesting guy to
just departing a little bit well tally
about him I became aware that he was
involved in a feud which goes back a
very long time between the Interior and
timber and basically the rest of the
sewers so in the Civil War they actually
papasan script were fighting against
what the Empire for want of a better
word but they were also fighting with
each other so they had used to have to
put British troops in between those two
sections the the other thing is we
became aware or I became aware of the
training with buffer zone for a while
that he was involved man and we would
often be on campus in a canteen and they
had all concept-car betweens you'd get a
young boy running
tell the black
cashier that someone was on campus
looking for buffers on I wanted to get
him down assassinate him and then they
would come and give the message to us
and then we would blame like tracks so
there's all kinds of interesting stuff
going on behind the surface but I'll
show you something about fiddlestick
fighting later and Johnny Cage right
later right a a very popular song called
for the very jazzy beat called bullets
pop off a song it's a song YouTube if
you want to have a look at it okay
getting back to our biology it's really
important I think to master some key
concepts so I won't spend too much time
on this it's basically a list of things
that I think you need to know some
axioms of hot ology so human combative
babe behavior is rooted in our evolution
human combative behavior can be divided
into two basic forms effective impotent
predatory and it's inseparably linked to
weapons use so we we've been through
this I don't think we talked about emic
and etic this is terminology developed
or draped by dragger very roughly anemic
is the insider's point of view and etic
is the outsider's point of view so my
example of being emic would be as
someone who's done Zulus fighting I
thought some of the customs and involved
in salute stick fighting so later on
when you see me do some stick fighting I
was kind of put on the what would you
say put to the test I was peacefully
filming a demonstration of holistic
fighting and then they came up to me and
gave me a shield and stick the person
that I was due to fight
hung back a little bit so I feel sorry
for any oh goody yeah I can hit this guy
or can I or is it okay so I walked up to
him and I I hit on his shield which is a
signal to say yeah let's go and he he
understood then that I knew him a little
about what I was doing so the fight
commences at that point but you'll see
that okay two phases of combat
we've already really dealt with this but
I'd like to show you a little film and
especially for people to whom this is
new it may provide some reinforcement of
what hunter Armstrong was talking apart
so here we've got a wildcat
you
okay well I hope this reinforces what
the chip was talking about you see the
low posture stalking posture beep the
gaze
okay so we've got intense concentration
on the target or prey so intent we have
stealthy movement no vocalization the
prey is unaware of the stalker postures
functional so the cat is ready to
explode at any moment then we have intra
species example so this is a effective
aggression
that gets your attention
thank you much that's what we want it's
good it's obviously humping out to make
self look bigger a heavy eye contact
vocalization chip briefly referred to
eyeball Ivor's felt he was the was to an
ethologist who popularized this idea of
effective and predatory babe behavior or
aggression and he actually drew on a the
table was arena originally developed by
guy berlin and a DJ race so chip dealt
with this two phases of combat in some
depth with a two-part article entitled
the two phases of combatives in hop loss
seven number two and number three okay
as chip mentioned humans also had the
capability of pseudo predatory
aggression so we can treat other humans
as prey and again he mentioned sometimes
people also try to talk of themselves as
the people or humans and they don't
extend the same courtesy to others I
would say the sniper is a classic
example of the pseudo predator levitra
introduced you to light miller public
chenko 309 confirmed kills on the
eastern front fighting in the russian
army against the germans 36 or belief of
the people she killed or believed to
have been snipers german snipers the
civil marshal draggers paradox was not
all martial arts or fighting arts and
not all forty arts or martial arts so
one of his favorite tricks was to ask
the audience who here does martial art
and people would raise their hands and
saying I do Aikido or I do karate
I did judo and he would say that's not a
martial art which made some people very
unhappy yeah so how do you become a hot
Lola gist I think getting old copies of
hot loss and hoplite is a good start in
a couple of articles dragger addressed
this
he advocated the minimum education
bachelor's degree not in a particular
specialization or but you should be
aiming in terms of comparative study you
should train in a weapon so on and you
should understand the key concepts and
axioms of topology so what do you need
to get started I'd say write things down
keep a diary I've already mentioned
access to hoplite and hoplites and I
think perhaps that the key to the whole
thing is understanding the forms of
aggression I just mentioned affective
aggression predatory aggression and
pseudo praying predatory aggression okay
the good news is that it's all around us
Burton so hopped ology as a window into
mankind I'll try and give you some
examples in the past I've suggested
certain subjects or areas for
investigation London India the horse
cultures of Central Asia and the cattle
cultures of the eastern seaboard of
Africa but I'd also like to make it make
the point that you don't have to send
off to an exotic locale to do hot ology
the good news is that it's really all
around us if you know where to look so
let's take a look
these are all-time favorites of mine and
long hauls
you
okay we don't want to belabor the point
simple
the idea so you can see that same
techniques have been applied to the
animal and to the fellow human being so
I find that crossover very interesting
okay
throughout human history successive
waves of horse lighting peoples have
added and flowed across Central Asia the
Mongols probably been the best-known
they seem quite aware of the fact that
handling livestock functions both to
install a cool mindset and provide
practice in wrestling so I found this
interesting last point historically the
less hunts of the long-lost certainly
influence in military tactics I think
this is generally accepted by historians
so again the hunting equals the
predatory mindset and a cool calculating
approach some other favorites of mine or
the Silvius I wrote an article for
hopless on holistic fighting and when I
was writing I remembered a book I'd read
fairly recently at that stage Don
Central in human history by their famous
historian William McNeil and he comments
on how the military reforms in earlier
announced Europe actually he's talking
about the reintroduction of drill in the
case of the Zulus the Riverdance
especially the main group dances
function as a form of drill what's
particularly interesting is how the sets
of male bonding so let's take a quick
look at some axillary dancing
[Music]
okay so you're learning to be of
information you're getting a male
bonding and then you're also learning to
use weapons with people on either side
of you
they didn't really show very clearly
there I lied but there's a famous
stomper other cities have which would
probably be the idea the theory is you
use your shield to hook away your pen
and shield turning and then put in your
a so guy as he goes down you do a big
stomping kick okay
okay the e McMahon so as I said as the
result of hanging out with people like
shipment I ended up doing well with
premature laugh my lifetime commitment
to apology so this is the one I was
talking about where I was peacefully
photographing or video reading something
and then I got put this is about 1982 or
83 put on the spot that's what I was
trying to say
there we go just a tiny bit things is it
for fun okay I said I had to try and
provide you with some examples of how
you can do hop low dodgy without even
leaving your home so that's my next
example thought it would make Alex happy
[Applause]
of the tracksuits stand in front of the
okay it would be fun to see a whole
illogical sort of assessment of it and
the last example I have to give you is
from Europe from Spain to be precise I'd
like you to keep an eye for a year
open for a young lady with a white
t-shirt this is a festival in Galicia
northern Spain
[Applause]
how can they stop it if you look
carefully you'll see evidence of prior
planning and teamwork so their basic
team it's three people one person riding
the horse one person with the arm over
the horse and trying to obscure the
horse's vision and also getting the
twist on the neck and the other person
on the tail there's the young lady
[Applause]
stop it's hard to go but maybe we can go
just five seconds right but if you look
at the girl she is it's just quite calm
and she's she's talking to her team
telling me what to do
[Applause]
just a little bit more
yes okay
so that's pretty much why presentation
maybe we can I'd like to give you this
list of the things I brainstormed how
can we commemorate DFDS life and legacy
that would be one thing we could do
establish a spawning trophy support and
encourage the DFT biography start a
project to collect and publish DFDS
letters make grants available for Hubble
illogical research fund an annual
lecture or conference and hot lava tea
set up a course in ecology founded
graduates when thinking online might be
the way to go with that set up a college
library or museum at a search of a
suitable tertiary institution conduct to
a court and publish series of interviews
with us associated and support a
newsletter and journal provide a
discussion forum for those interested my
apology okay I think that's about it
I'd like to go back just because for me
this is a phenomenal picture from 1979
when Liam although he does look like
something out of Monty Python I think
you all realize from the zulus stick
fighting this is a man who knows how to
take a hit and keep going what I think
is is crucial to understand and I do
what I liked out of Liam's presentation
is you don't have to go to Papua New
Guinea you don't have to get a South
Africa to start thinking about the world
around you in terms emic and etic and
using the three axioms you don't have to
go far and I think what is important for
all of us today is that you go and leave
this event thinking more about ecology
and potentially what you can learn from
it no one's going to ask you to become
suddenly the director of the IHS you
said over there he gonna be happy with
me but what we would love to understand
and see out of this is that you go away
and start thinking about your own
training and start looking at these
principles so having said that
Liam's gone through part of his career
and part of his experiences and
certainly I know there are a lot of
books may be put aside which we will
make sure that you get a list of to
share at this moment Mike where the mic
is hanging around is there anyone who
has a question they'd like to ask of
Liam nothing specific sir
I left me again sorry not to I notice in
your your slide about qualifications to
study Hippolyta you talked about the you
McMahon but you also stiffly mention
practitioner of a of a weapons art I was
when I could spend a bit more on on why
that specific requirement mm-hmm well I
think it fits in with the axioms of
topology I think it's it's really hard
to exclude weapons as chip mentioned
even before humans were fully human four
hundred thousand years ago they were
using Spears so to a certain extent with
koval to use weapons so I think that's
the basic reason yeah learning other
questions I'd like to sorry I have a
question there sir wondering if you
could elaborate a bit more on why
effective aggression is called effective
in what sense
or is that term being used and why that
term well we're using it to mean
emotional arousal so you're affected
mm-hm essentially we it's a descriptive
term it shows in certain contexts humans
naturally become emotional in conflict
so it's a descriptive term that just
says in this type of conflict situation
this fellow and I are facing off or
angry or we're trying to produce a
conflict that will end in one
establishing dominance over the other
that will be causing emotional arousal
it's a natural outcome of an effective
aggression
so it's barely descriptive it's not
meant to be an outcome we seek and
indeed the fighting professional is
going to try to avoid that type of
behavior thank you very much
I have a question myself and I'm gonna
put him on the spot we have a lot about
the field trip one of the things that
interest me is man thank you
one of the things that interests me out
of it maybe you've heard the rumors that
Drager was poisoned during his travel I
know that you had a constantly runny
nose on your travels what what do you
know about this story and and what
happened in terms of because anecdotally
you know we we heard
hear a lot about it is there anything
you can share about that story well I
was on antibiotics which were being
doled out to me by by chip it was the
medic on the trip and I was actually
getting slightly bit we before they
really got sick okay we went to a
village in an area of Archaea which is
not known for being kind to outsiders
and problem very probably or in all
probability a meal that we had in the
small village was responsible for all of
us becoming sick I ate the least because
I was already sick and as I said I was
on antibiotics the others immediately
got very very very sick and
so yeah with the supposition is we were
poisoned
this area was famous for having a
special recipe as it were for dealing
with outsiders yeah and I guess the
other factor chip remembers stuff better
than me so maybe I should ask you some
questions later because a few things
have come back to me since we were
talking about this incident yesterday he
remembers some things that are actually
forgotten all about like one of the
village headman turning his back on us
so anyway we were all sick when we came
back Drago was a very driven person he
had his own agenda he had lots of things
to do so he found him very hard to sit
back and rest and go to hospital like he
probably should have and as a result his
sickness got worse and worse until it
became too late Thank You Liam and we'll
have some more time which Steve if you
don't mind we to get on cam time we'll
have everybody presented back later and
you can ask a question then I'm gonna
stop by saying once again thank you very
much Liam for coming all this way
Australia
[Applause]
[Music]
you